In fewer than two decades, the Spider-Man
franchise has already amassed a history
of stops and restarts. But the most surprising
were the sudden cancellations of
Amazing Spider-Man 3 and the spin-offs planned
to follow. It was confusing and
strange, but there's an interesting story
behind why the sequel to a successful movie
got tossed in the garbage.
THE PLANNED SEQUELS
Sony's plans for Amazing Spider-Man 3 and
4 were pretty crazy. The plan involved
not only resurrections for both Gwen Stacy
and her father, but also Gwen becoming
something like the Spider-Gwen character who
has since debuted in the comics in
2015. (For those not familiar with the comics,
"Spider-Gwen" is basically, "Gwen
Stacy, but with the powers of Spider-Man.
And is from another dimension.") To add
to that, Sony also planned some villain-centric
films as well: Sinister Six and Venom.
The ideas were all intriguing. But then, seemingly
overnight, those plans got
THE PLANS GET CANCELLED
Amazing Spider-Man 3 and 4 were both planned
and even had release dates set for
2016 and 2018. Paul Giamatti also confirmed
that he'd return as the Rhino for the
third movie. But then the movies began to
get delayed. Also, Marc Webb, a huge part
of the first two films success, stated that
he'd only return to direct the third film
and
only act as consultant for the fourth, which
wasn't a good sign. Ultimately, all of the
planned movies got cancelled.
GARFIELD GOT HIMSELF FIRED
Andrew Garfield helped pave the way for this
new direction for Spider-Man. It's also
the actual reason plans for Amazing Spider-Man
3 got canceled. Garfield was
supposed to attend a gala after the 2014 World
Cup in Brazil, where he'd have been
announced as the star of Amazing Spider-Man
3 by Sony bigwig Kaz Hirai, but
Garfield cancelled at the last minute. Garfield
most likely cancelled due to feeling
under the weather from the long flight there,
which is understandable. But still,
Hirai felt slighted. Execs felt that it was
a slight against the company as well. So
Garfield was out. A man lost a job because
someone's feelings got hurt. That's
professionalism!
THE SONY HACKS AND THE NEW DIRECTION
The Sony hacks from late-2014 revealed a lot
about the sudden changes with their
Spider-Man franchise. According to the leaked
emails, the lukewarm reviews it
received were enough to spur Sony into taking
the character in another direction. It
involved the hiring of another actor to play
the role of Peter Parker, Tom Holland -
the youngest actor to take the role so far,
suggested a desire to keep Parker young.
But this wasn't the only big news to come
from the hacks…
JOINING THE MARVEL CINEMATIC UNIVERSE
Sony worked out a deal with Marvel to bring
Spider-Man into Marvel's cinematic
universe. Fanboys and fangirls around the
world squealed in delight. Since then, it's
been revealed that Spidey would make his debut
in a big way, as part of Captain
America: Civil War. This puts Spidey in line
to participate in Marvel's climactic
Avengers: Infinity War movies, something a
lot of fans, want to see.
Thanks for watching, and don't forget to like and subscribe if you want more.